i'm the type of individual i'm a great
listener i can hear and i've made a
fortune of just listening to people
the very thing that disqualified me
vision used
to qualify me sometimes when somebody
tells you the truth
you've got to learn not to be offended
and use that because it is the truth
need motivation what's your top 10 with
the live
nation top
for my top 10
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you
are probably the most ambitious person
in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best richard montanez and my take
on his top
10 rules for success enjoy okay let's
kick it off with rule number one
influence with your work ethic my
grandfather said something to me that
i i say it's the reason i'm successful
and i love to
tell young people this you know we've
spoken at harvard notre dame some of the
top schools in the country
and i always say this and he asked me
what are you going to do i said
i'm the janitor i have to mop the floors
he looked at me and he said when you
walk that floor you make sure that it
shines
so when people see it they know that a
mountain has mocked it
and my dad said listen to your grandpa
you know i actually took that on
and this is what i tell people and you
know maybe some people will get it in
somewhat i say
as much as i love the compensation the
promotions frito-lay hot cheetos pepsi
the truth is it was never about them
it was always about my last name
you know it was always about that you
know and
i'm mopping the best i could and i saw
that i was having an
influence and people say how can you
have an influence when you're just the
janitor
and i told people there's no such thing
as just a janitor when you believe in
your heart you're going to be the best
no such thing as a waiter a bus driver
and what was happening was
my job was to clean the bathrooms the
lunchroom
and all the uh managers uh offices
before they came in in the morning
so the workers would go into the
bathroom and the bathroom was spotless
it smelled good and they come out with a
smile like hey
who cleaned that and then they go into
the lunchroom and it was you know
spotless now you know i wasn't
complaining like throw your own trash i
was just cleaning and smell
good and then in the morning the
managers were
opening up their offices and saying wow
my office is spotless who you know
who did this and everybody pointed to
that janitor
and said richard montenez and that's
when i learned that
at a very young age that i had an
influence
i could influence people without saying
one word
by my work ethics i i influenced i put a
smile on their face and never even said
anything
and then i realized too you know some of
these quotes quote that
are ancient exactly that they're ancient
somebody said
you get promoted by who you know i said
that's not true you get promoted by
who knows you you can say you know the
ceo or the manager all you want but they
don't
and that's what was happening as a
janitor
people were knowing who i was just
because of my work ethics i hadn't even
spoken a word yet
rule number two be a good listener young
students today
um don't have those abilities to sit
down with you know i always say sit down
with your grandpa
maybe he wasn't ceo or something but
listen to
her stories his stories whatever because
there's a wealth of
information in there they overcame they
were through some
tough times some generations that
they've done some things and
i always find it fascinating when i can
find someone who's
older than me and wants to talk to me
i'll just sit there and listen to when i
just
and you never know somebody says where
do you get your ideas
i said by listening to people you know
people will say things and they don't
even understand what they said but i'm
the type of individual i'm a great
listener i can hear and i've made a
fortune of just listening to people
rule number three have a vision there
isn't anything that you can't accomplish
if you have vision you see
when i started with frito-lay 1976
i didn't have a whole lot of going for
me
i had no education was told i would
never be anything
but i had one thing i had vision
and this is what vision did for me
when others saw what i was
vision saw what i would become
the very thing that disqualified me
vision used
to qualify me rule number four use the
truth
two weeks my that time manager called me
up
you know the probation period was was
was uh
it was actually 30 days and 15 days had
gone by and he said uh
i gotta let you go yeah i can't tell
i mean i didn't even have a hard time
talking about it because it was so long
ago
but what it did to me i was just totally
devastated like
you know i i blew the only shot that i
would
somebody like myself because you have to
understand
you know people say you don't make right
choices when you're in the hood
or ain't too many good choices coming to
the hood you know i
i don't frown on anybody who's from that
area because that's where i come from
you know i come from the ghetto
my leadership is from the hood so i just
thought
man it ain't gonna come again and i blew
it
you know so i begged him like man you
know please you know let me
let me you know what did i do then he
said well
you know you don't show any initiative
i didn't know what the word meant and
here's what he was saying
is uh he told me to mop this
this this and i did it so fast and so
good
that i was finishing too early so i
didn't know what to do
so guess what i did is i mopped it again
so i just i just kept cleaning the same
stuff within those eight hours
knowing that i'd done it in four hours
but listen to this no one had ever done
it in four hours
so he said you showed no initiative and
i was
i didn't know what that meant so i went
and i begged him i said just give me two
more weeks i will be the most
initiative person you ever see please
please and
and you know it was part of my destiny
he said okay you got two weeks so i went
home
and judy's been my teacher my
inspiration you know
i said judy i almost got fired she said
what happened and
i said he said i didn't have any
initiative and i said what is that
and then she began to explain to me and
it it hurt
i mean it hurt inside and it hurts so
much that it took me over the edge
i'm never going to hear that word again
no one ever going to say that richard
has no initiative i knew where i
where i was at at that time i knew there
was racial discrimination everywhere
you know not to point any fingers but
you know that that was the 70s you know
we just came out of the 60s so i didn't
have a whole lot of choices you know i
quit school i didn't have a high school
diploma
you know i just saw that you know uh i
was i'm a visionary
you know and the problem with being a
visionary is we're five to ten years
ahead of everyone else you gotta have
patience
let everybody else catch up so i knew um
you know i wasn't going to get mad i was
hurt and broken because
it was the truth it was the truth i
didn't have any initiative
and that's why i teach young people
sometimes when somebody tells you the
truth
you've got to learn not to be offended
and use that because it is the truth
even there's a scripture in the bible
that paul even wrote that i love
he said am i your enemy because i tell
you the truth
you know and today people can't take
that well i'm quitting i'm getting the
hell out of here you know he can't talk
to me like that
you know sometimes i say you know don't
get abused
but hang in there you know uh
build something and that's how i felt
like i didn't have one i wanted that job
real bad
i wasn't gonna quit just because you
know it was true i didn't have any
initiative
so he didn't lie to me he wasn't picking
on me
he probably one of the best things that
anybody could ever said to me
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief i've
designed a special
free training to help you do it the
science says it can take up to 254 days
of consecutive action
to build a new habit and i want that for
you i want you to build the habit
of self-belief so what i'm going to do
is email you every day
for 254 days a link to an
unlisted video that will shift your
belief forward
to get on it for free the link to join
is in the description below
people kind of dumped on
uh what he called it fast food industry
if i had to do it again i could work for
mcdonald's one of the
real reasons we don't do the things that
frighten us
is because we are afraid of being judged
i want you to write
five questions down that you're going to
ask yourself
three or four times a day five questions
that are positive
for yourself rule number five stand out
that was an interesting time i was a
young boy during the civil rights
movement of the 60s
now what i like to tell people is that i
wasn't old enough to have an impact on
the movement
but i was old enough that the movement
had an impact on me
here's how the story goes we're in a one
one room apartment
my mom's getting me ready for school
because i was being bussed
from my school to an all english
speaking school across town
and i remember i'm crying because i
don't want to go to school my mom says
why not and i said because everybody
speaks english you know it's not fair
for me i can't speak a word before
bilingual no translators
that's the other thing i'm glad you
brought that up is people forget is that
you know during my days there were no
bilingual classes if
if you wanted your license you need to
know english it was it was it was pretty
difficult it was different
it was really different and um so
my uncle takes me to the corner and uh
here comes the yellow bus
and then there goes the yellow bus so
i'm kind of happy and telling my uncle i
guess they're
not going to stop for us there was about
10 of us waiting
then all of a sudden we hear this big
pop and bang and
we see this green bus coming up the hill
smoking and
that's the bus that they sent for us and
i remember i told my uncle
it's just like it happened yesterday
that's why i say sometimes you got to go
back
you know so you can catch some of those
wisdoms and some of the things that
happened to you so
i'm telling my uncle why can't i ride
the yellow bus like the other kids
and he has no explanations i don't know
this is a
bus that they sent for you you know
jeremy it wasn't
until i was an adult that i finally
realized
why they sent that green bus and it was
society at the time
saying that this group of children this
time
group of ten they're not good enough
to ride the yellow bus let's put them on
a green bus
parade them across town so that the
whole town can see
that because of who they are they're not
good enough to ride
and as a young boy that uh i took that
on because you have to understand i
didn't know what diversity was i didn't
know what discrimination was i didn't
know what race was
but one thing that i didn't know and i
knew my color
so for me it was like oh dark skin
is kind of like a second class citizen
that's all i knew
oh okay so i began to take that on i'm
not good enough
for the yellow bus so we get to school
i don't understand the word the
teacher's saying but i always said this
that there's
one sound that's international that
every child knows that sound
and that's the sound of the recess
recess that's right or lunch
so matter of fact it was lunch so it was
uh lunch time so it was all a relief
and you know my group we got our lunches
and you know we sat outside
and uh i pulled my lunch out and i was
getting ready to take a bite
and i put it back i put it back because
everybody in that whole
playground was staring at me and the
reason they were staring at me
because it was a burrito and what people
need to understand that this was 1963
the world hadn't seen a burrito yet
right you know contrary to popular
belief taco bell then introduced the
breed of the world me and my mom didn't
but the fact is i was embarrassed yeah
so i went home and i told my mom in
spanish said you know
make me a bologna sandwich and a cupcake
like the other kid
because i don't want to be different and
i told my mom why do i have to ride the
green bus
why do i have to be this color why do i
have to speak this language why do i
have to eat
this food i want to fit in like everyone
else
but my mom i've always said she's a
marketing genius she said no this is who
you are
and that was wednesday when i was
brought to that school so wednesday was
my burrito nightmare
thursday she made me two burritos and
she said here's one for you
and here's one to share with a friend
so i went to school shared a burrito
with a friend
on thursday friday i was selling
burritos for 25 cents a piece
and thus the entrepreneurialism kicks in
that's when i realized that even at a
young age that you know what
maybe just maybe there is something
special about
different being different and i finally
realized jeremy that none of us were
created to fit in we were all created to
stand
out i think that's what we need to teach
our young people
is quit trying to fit in because it's
never going to happen because you aren't
created to fail you were created to
stand out
so for me that became a revelation
that led to a revolution of my life i
knew that okay
i'm different but it's okay and i really
started to
fall in love with my culture and who i
was rule number six
get your revelation in life
um all you need is one revelation
to create a revolution and i didn't know
that
then but i was about to get the biggest
revelation of my life that was going to
create the biggest revolution
in my life but the revolution in my
company
that was going to lead to a revolution
in the industry
so i like to say you know and i get
excited about this i like to say that
yes i change corporate america
and people will say you're so full of
yourself i said i am
you know because i know what i did and i
think that's something that we have to
teach young people too so i
revolutionize how you see corporate
america today it's not the same
it was 20 30 years ago i think when you
know
how i got that revelation is i was
looking and i saw
all these spices and then i looked at
our products and like ah we didn't
really have a lot of spices so that was
a revelation
create something with spices for those
who enjoy
you know i mean everybody loves spices
today you know i mean
especially latina yeah you especially
enjoy it yeah you know
you know so that's what we decided to do
and then again here comes another
revelation i didn't know what to do i
just like okay i got to make something
i didn't know what that was you know
what that would look like what it would
be right but i'm sitting in my old house
and you know here comes the
ilotte man and i buy
honey nothing he puts the chile on it
the cheese and
everything this is the truth remember
one revelation
what is a revelation something that was
always there but it's been
revealed to you so i took a bite
and when i looked at it was like this
looks like a cheeto
what if i put chili on a cheeto
a crazy ridiculous idea what are you
doing yeah someone told my wife hey we
got to make some
some special chili so i went to the
plant and got some cheetos with no
cheese on it
took them home and me and my wife you
know we worked on a recipe we tried this
we tried that
we finally got it down she took some to
work i took some to work
everybody loved it wow i said man
richard you got to call the ceo this is
great
well keep in mind um you don't call the
ceo
right you know i didn't know any better
that's what i'm saying sometimes
you've got to be willing you know to do
the things that you're not sure of
rule number seven dream back in my days
you know when i first started off
you know me you know i i've i've been
with my wife since we were kids
we've been together 40 years we've been
married 35 years been together 40 years
you know but when we got together we
didn't have any dreams
that's why i like to tell young people
you know what dream let it be wild
it's okay throw it out there see my dad
my grandfather were good men but they
didn't know how to dream because
all they were doing was working so when
i started working i started working full
time when i was in the third grade
my grandfather picked grapes my dad
picked grapes
then i picked grapes so we didn't have
time to dream
but we had hope and our hope that
someday we would have a better future
that someday maybe someday we don't have
to worry about how we're going to feed
our kids today
maybe someday we'll have a bank account
maybe someday judy you and i will be
able to write a check
maybe someday we'll we'll live in that
neighborhood that we used to go
trick-or-treating
and they'd throw us out because they
said you don't live in this
but i remember i didn't want to go
trick-or-treating to delario
there was no candy in there
me judy used to go across town where you
get the big the big hershey bars
but after a while after a few knocks
they would
realize you know what this is not your
neighborhood is it
go back we we were never hurt
because we didn't know what
discrimination was we didn't know what
it was we just
we don't belong there we got to go back
to the other side of the track
young people i want to tell you today
listen to me young people
you don't need anybody's permission to
become great
[Music]
and if you feel you need somebody's
permission well i'm here to give it to
you today you have my permission to be
great
rule number eight take initiative i
turned it around you know i
i did my job in four hours and i was on
there there was a wall that separated
production from the offices and the
lunchrooms
because in production there was you know
quality control you couldn't go in there
unless you had hair nets and you know
protective equipment so what i did
is i borrowed some protective equipment
and i went in there and i started
hanging out with the operators
the people that were running the lines
and i started taking their trash outside
uh and then if they want this is cool
this is the truth i don't know you know
people will like it but if they wanted a
cigarette break
you know to go outside and smoke cause
you know this is this is 70 right you
know everybody smokes
uh so i would say well just show me what
to do you know you just be gone for five
minutes and they're like uh i don't know
like come on i'm a mechanic you know i
never really am
you know and so they would teach me you
know uh
how to watch the line and they would go
outside
you know and i'd do that for a couple of
weeks and so so the other managers were
telling my manager like hey uh
the guy on your crew that mops in the
night man hey uh
i just want to thank you for letting him
take my trash out my guys helped him and
they were like what who did that
you know and he was like like okay he
was like no one had ever done that
you know you heard the old statement
that's not my job
after he told after he told me that i i
never said i said
i'm employed here that is my job you
know
that is my job and and little by little
i learned
how to run the the dorito lines you know
how to
and it is it is like being a pilot it's
not you know people say you just make
chips oh no no no man
it's like you got to go to pilot school
to learn how to make doritos and potato
chips and freedom believe me it takes a
couple years to be a master
rule number nine stay away from haters
because there's always the dollars you
know and i like to tell young people you
know
stay away from the haters you know and
people said well what do you do
that's i'm the giants oh you're the
you're just the janitor and i've said
you know what
there's no such thing as just a janitor
there's no such thing as just the way
there's no such thing as a there's no
such
thing as just when you believe in your
heart that you're going to be the best
and i believed in my heart and people
were taking that and i
that floor shine and rule number 10 the
last one before a very special bonus
clip
is love yourself i like who i am
i hope all of you love me
but if you don't it's okay you know why
because i love me
young people fall in love with yourself
because when you fall in love with
yourself
there's a freedom to be yourself now
i've got some special bonus clips that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
wanna know what was your single biggest
takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
when you just watch a video and you get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation
we need to take some action but when you
watch a video you get motivated and you
create a specific
plan of action that number jumps from 35
to 91 chance of you following through
and when you publicly commit to other
people like leaving a comment down in
this video
your number jumps to 95 chains of you
actually following through on the plan
you set for yourself
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
so i can celebrate you everything
created has a step-by-step protocol and
sometimes you just need to break out in
order to break through
young executives listen
stay away from people who discourage you
and hang out with people who encourage
you
you know what it is to discourage
someone that means to go into their
heart and pull out the courage that
they're never the same
you know what it means to encourage
someone it means to grab courage you put
it in their
inner being where they're never the same
that's what you need to be spending time
with people who encourage you
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel
just for it go check it out the link is
right there next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there